they are hummed a space a few feet off
the ground Rippling like a calm lake
disturbed by a stone Throne at its
surface not that there was anyone around
to see which of course begged the
age-old question that a baffled
philosophers scientists and pretty much
everyone with a working brain for
centuries that being if an
interdimensional fracture leading to an
infinite Multiverse of endlessly
recurring realities opens up in a hotel
resort bedroom in Mexico and nobody is
there to see it then did it really
happen at all well in this instance it
really did the flash of light a figure
came tumbling Through the Wormhole
fizzling out of existence in one place
only to arrive somewhere similar behind
him the purplish Terror in the very
fabric of reality sealed itself shut as
quickly and inexplicably as it had
opened setting up his Hawaiian shirt a
disheveled mess the man blinked through
his blurred vision Eddie Brock was
unsure of his headache was the result of
an intense hangover or the process of
being flung between universes seemingly
at random are we back a voice in the
back of Eddie's head growled I have no
idea pal Petty replied aloud looking
around the vacant hotel room the last of
the daylight fading as the sun set we
should eat the gravelly voice replied
I'm hungry that's all you ever think
about he replied I don't even have any
money on me besides don't you'd think we
should try and figure out where we are
first nope in seconds a dark gooey
substance morphed over Eddie from head
to toe encasing him and his clothes it
formed a body a towering hulking monster
with wide white eyes in the shape of
teardrops its mouth was filled with rows
of long razor sharp teeth the black goo
was constantly shifting in fact it was
alive an alien symbiont bonded with its
human host in order to survive together
the symbiota and Eddie were Venom
bursting out of the hotel's balcony as
night rapidly fell venom-fired organic
webs from his wrists and swung through
the city in search of food agent Hardy
hated field work he'd imagine working
for the SCP Foundation would be full of
action and thrilling Espionage and had
enrolled in undercover training hoping
he'd be sent on missions to stealthily
infiltrate other anomalous organizations
like the Church of the broken God or
Global occult Coalition instead he was
assigned to Deep Cover which was
Foundation euphemism for stay put and
keep your eyes peeled just in case you
spot something unusual he had been
stationed in Mexico City and was forced
to work a menial job in a tiny little
convenience store to maintain cover a
waste of his Advanced combat and
reconnaissance training he thought agent
Hardy badly wanted more and found it
personally insulting that the foundation
sought fit to waste an asset like him
while he should have been made part of
one of their mobile task forces only add
thing to that perceived insult was the
fact that nothing at all unusual or even
remotely anomalous ever seemed to happen
nearby that is until a seven foot tall
500 pound oily black monster came
barreling into the convenience store
barged its way over to The Confectionary
aisle and started shoveling fistfuls of
chocolate into its mouth all before
dashing back out and Swinging away with
as many candy bars as it could carry in
one arm Hardy if somebody robbed your
store that's a job for the local police
department the board voice Foundation
operator replied over the radio as agent
Hardy contacted command no not just
somebody something hearty yelled while
the store's customers ran screaming from
the scene it's a goddamn alien I saw
with my own eyes it's huge hold on one
moment the operator replied before
turning to a colleague still audible
over the radio meanwhile agent Hardy
tapped his foot impatiently didn't we
get a bliff near there what I don't know
the exact time about an hour cargo tops
any read on what it was interdimensional
disturbance that could be connected look
how do you want me to proceed Hardy
barked uh follow at a distance agent
Hardy the operator replied be advised do
not engage with the creature under any
circumstances it could be carrying any
number of unknown pathogens or diseases
we don't have cures for if it is from
Another Universe strict observation only
mobile task force no 6 is inbound to
contain your alien agent Hardy turned
and dashed out of the store sprinting
down the street a little way in the
distance Venom had been swinging from
buildings they were singing I got you
under my skin to themselves without a
care on the world before landing on a
rooftop and starting to ravenously munch
on their remaining chocolate bars all
delicious Venom growled after finishing
their feast so when are we gonna work on
getting back home Eddie asked half of
the Symbiotes protective mask retracting
to show him underneath this might be our
then I'm retorted this planet looks the
shame in every Universe look I really
think we ought to prioritize getting out
of here the human half of them argued
that should be our priority not feeding
you Eddie we've been over this I need
the Lettermen to live and since you get
all internet at me for eating brains we
have to get it from a more socially
acceptable source the alien creature
replied
unless what broadcast unless you wanna
go find some bad guys brains to eat the
Symbiote queried hey you someone yelled
hold it right there as if On Cue the
sounds of weapons being mocked and
loaded interrupted their conversation in
the time since agent Hardy had called it
in the foundation's mobile task force
had arrived on the rooftop Hardy was
with them hanging back and letting the
other operatives move in to apprehend
the alien drawing themselves to their
full height Venom turned to face the
approaching Squad of armed soldiers
their face returning to its full sharp
tooth form bad guys Venom ground
grinning wildly guys with guns pointed
at us I'm gonna guess probably bad guys
Eddie answered before noticing logo
emblazed on the mtf's uniforms hold up
SCP Foundation like the life Foundation
who cares Undeclared their dinner open
fire the MTF Commander yelled before
being suddenly silenced Venom had
grabbed him and was beginning to close
his Jaws around his head the remaining
members of the task force followed their
squad Leader's final command and pulled
their triggers the rooftop erupted into
a handle of gunfire bullets impacting
with Venom's oily form but causing no
damage bouncing off their outer
gelatinous skin they lunged at another
of the MTF Troopers wrenching the man's
weapon from his hands and hurling it
away before grabbing him by the ankle
with Incredible strength Venom flung The
operative around in the air as if he was
a ragdoll swinging him into the other
troops sending them flying hanging back
from the fight agent Hardy was trying to
observe the creature's attack patterns
although it seemed to just be
chaotically flinging an MTF operative
around as a weapon rather than deploying
any form of actual technique he wanted
to spot an opening a weakness anything
that could take down this hulking alien
monster but not one was presenting
itself that is until Venom finished
swinging that helpless Foundation
Soldier around and threw the man over
their shoulder the MTF Trooper dropped
limply down to street level landing on a
parked car with a loud crash and the
sound of glass shattering which was
followed by The Wailing of the car's
emergency alarm the screeching noise
seemingly caused Venom to reel from
their fight with the MTF roaring and
gripping their head to drown out the
alarm sound hearty muttered to himself
its weakness is sound instantly he
turned to one of the other MTF soldiers
and dashed towards him while Venom was
lashing out in an enraged State the
strands of the Symbiote were recoiling
exposing Eddie contained beneath agent
Hardy grabbed the nearest Foundation
operative and violently struck him in
the face taking advantage of the
trooper's shock to pull his weapon out
of his hands and push him towards the
edge of the rooftop he delivered another
blow feeling his fellow Foundation
agent's nose cracking against his fist
as he took out all his frustrations with
is undercover posting the task force
operative could barely believe what was
happening too dumbfounded and in too
much pain to protest even when he did
weekly lift his arms to defend his face
agent Hardy effortlessly swatted them
away and smashed his forehead into the
other agent's face dazing him as he
dragged him right up to the ledge there
was nothing between the captive Soldier
just a sheer multi-story drop down to
street level lining him up agent Hardy
shoved the other men off the roof so he
landed on a second car its alarm started
blaring the horn too as the Fallen
agent's body went through the windshield
adding even more loud noises to the max
such a deafening combination of loud
sounds caused Venom to Keel over roaring
in pain as the symbiote's main weakness
pierced it if the noise continued for
too long it would force Eddie and his
alien accomplice to separate and so the
slimy form defensively retreated into
its host leaving him alone wearing a
triumphant smug look on his face agent
Hardy marched over to the human being
that was left the alien form was gone
for now meaning he could just raise his
stolen weapon and strike Eddie hard in
the face knocking him out ready for the
foundation to take him and the Symbiote
in for examination after hours of
torture that agent Hardy had volunteered
to conduct personally the foundation had
learned that a sustained barrage of high
frequency sound waves could be used to
forcibly separate the gelatinous alien
life form from its host once they had
been parted Eddie Brock didn't need much
more containment than any other average
human while the Symbiote could be placed
in a glass tank for the foundation
researchers to take a closer look at the
creature seems to possess a
Consciousness its own Mobility it is an
entirely separate entity from Mr Brock
one of the researchers commented
observing a sample of the symbiont that
they had managed to slice off the larger
hole and was now slithering its way
around a smaller transparent containment
Cube that's pretty obvious Poindexter
agent Hardy retorted impatiently why
don't you give me something useful what
well the researchers stammered
intimidated by the imposing field
operative it appears to be rapidly
deteriorating that thing is dying Hardy
asked it seems so we've been able to
access some of the hive mind that it
shares with the rest of its kind
apparently these he checked his notes
planktar are able to share knowledge
across multiple realities but they need
to remain bonded to a host in order to
survive on their own their lifespans are
much shorter the researcher added but it
seems that once they have they increase
the host's strength replicate their own
Mass even use more of itself to create
weapons weapons the agent that code yes
yes anything it seems some of these
symbiotes could even create copies of
existing Weaponry that would act as an
extension of itself fully usable by the
host thank you doc that info should come
in pretty handy agent Hardy applied I I
beg your pardon agent the researcher
asked before agent Hardy's hand gripping
his throat silenced him elsewhere in the
facility Eddie Brock was yelling
demanding to be let free his only
thought was getting back to Venom aware
that his symbiotic partner would wither
and die if they remained apart for too
long thanks to their bond he knew Venom
was thinking the same thing this precise
moment and only spurred him on to try
and pull himself free he was handcuffed
to a chair barely able to move normally
the pair of them could get out of a jam
like this with no trouble after all
things were always easier when they were
together I got you Eddie started to sing
loudly and tunelessly under my skin
quiet snapped a foundation security
officer who stood nearby I got you they
ignore the garden continued making his
voice even louder deep in the heart of
me so deep in my heart that you're
really a part of me I got you oh I said
quiet the officer barked marching over
to Eddie baton raised threateningly with
a sudden unrelenting strike he kicked
the guard in the stomach with all the
force he could manage when did the
officer crumpled dropping to the floor
as he cast for air not letting up Eddie
kicked again this time his boot
connected with a man's jaw and knocked
him out it wouldn't last forever though
using his legs and with a great deal of
difficulty Eddie tried to lift the
handcuffed keys from the officer's belt
he hardly possessed perfect coordination
meaning it required a lot of trial and
error but knowing Venom needed him made
him all the more determined to try and
try again until finally Eddie pulled the
keys up with his boots lifted his legs
so they slid down and caught them in his
cuffed hand freeing himself he left the
unconscious security guard cuffed in his
place before making his way through the
facility as quickly and quietly as he
could it didn't matter that he had never
been there before he could sense the
Venom anywhere even though they were
apart all he had to do was follow the
pole to where it was being held however
he could have done with his symbiote
partner's protection when he arrived in
the lab something tore through Eddie's
shoulder embedding itself in his flesh
screaming with pain he lifted a hand to
the bleeding wound only to feel a second
shot strike him in the gut he could feel
the projectile in his hand gritting his
teeth he pulled it out it was a tooth
blood soaked and fired with the force of
a bullet it was then that Eddie looked
up and saw where from towering over him
agent Hardy looked almost unrecognizable
he had bonded with the sample cut off of
the Symbiote and it had encased his body
in a suit all of his own he had black
segmented plates like armor although
with the same gelatinous oily appearance
as Venom and his hand was what looked
like a submachine gun but was in
actuality something special that the
agent had requisitioned from the
foundation's anomalous Armory it was
scp-127 a weapon there like the Symbiote
was also an organic living being capable
of firing human-like teeth in the place
of bullets to make matters worse The
Shred of symbiote Hardy wore had cloned
its own versions of scp-127 their
handles extending into long black
tendrils that protruded from the agent's
back the rest of Venom was still
contained in the tank frantically
slithering against the glass trying to
free itself and get to Eddie if it did
it could heal his injuries and make
itself whole again stomping over to
where his wounded victim lay symbiote
infused Hardy pulled Eddie up from the
floor and lifted him to his feet making
sure he dug his symbiote coated thumb
into his wounds making Eddie cry out in
pain gotta be said Mr Brock Hardy grins
sadistically I can see why you'd want to
be merged with one of these things the
strength it gives you is
amazing enough to make anybody take you
serious
remind them not to underestimate you and
that's all from me getting a little
piece imagine how strong I'll be when
I'm combined with your little alien
friend there you should know Eddie
Winston Adam's a little picky about who
he hangs out with and trust me you're
not his type oh yeah agent Hardy roared
with his symbiote enhanced strength he
hurled Eddie across the lab with such
force that he smashed the glass tank
before colliding with the far wall and
landing in a heap Eddie was still
bleeding heavily from the teeth he'd
been shot with has venom tried and
that's weakened state to slide across
the floor to him only for Hardy to catch
it he lifted the rest of the dark gooey
symbiote and dangled it tauntingly over
Eddie as he lay bleeding out on the
floor you're nothing without this thing
attached to you Brock Hardy jeard in
fact even when you two were bonded on
that rooftop you were easy enough to
take down guess even together other you
two are nothing
no Eddie rasped weekly reaching his hand
up with the last of his fading strength
as he did Hardy didn't notice the
Symbiote reaching back to its host
together we're we're the alien life form
gave a surge and slipped over Eddie's
hand instantly his gunshot wound sealed
up and repaired just as the dark slimy
form encased him once more standing up
catching Hardy by surprise Venom gripped
the agent by the neck we're a lethal
protector you feel me they ground
grinning and showing off their sharp
rows of teeth Venom lifted agent Hardy
up and threw him hard enough to send him
crashing through the wall Landing a few
feet away glad to have you back came out
his voice good to be back Venom replied
were you singing Our Song earlier yeah
Eddie's side that's how I escaped before
they could continue their conversation
agent Hardy roared at them staggering
back to his feet he began firing scp-127
at Venom the various copies his symbiote
had created unleashing a barrage of 2
the projectiles at them they didn't
Ricochet off like regular bullets in
fact they seem to be strong enough to
shred through Venom's outer symbiote
skin until it added a chance to reform
ouch they roared oh yeah his guns shoot
teeth had he worn slightly too late this
guy sucks Venom growled no arguments
there Eddie replied he had a plan here
partner I am open to suggestions Eddie
the symbiotic half answered as they
retreated from the gunfire party
charging after them the agent launched a
thumb tackling Venom hitting them down
and delivering a vicious punch the force
of it split the Symbiote head apart
revealing Eddie beneath you don't
deserve this much power agent Hardy
yelled lifting one of his oily black
tooth firing guns to Eddie's exposed
face just as he fired Venom's mask
reformed in the nick of time to protect
its host as the tooth impacted their
face both Eddie and his symbiote partner
noticed something Hardy's symbiote
seemed to suffer the same damage slip
parting and then quickly reforming he's
just wearing a part of you right V Eddie
asked when we get hurt he gets hurt we
just need to hurt him enough to get them
to separate and you can get that part of
your body back Venom lifted their head
noticing a button on the wall of the
corridor the foundation had plenty of
Need for emergency alarms in case an
anomaly broke containment and sure
enough there was one labeled activate in
case of emergency raising one arm Venom
fired a line of organic web at the
button the screaming ringing sound had
both Venom and agent Hardy writhing in
agony the Symbiote began retracting from
the foundation field agent as the alarm
blared he weakly tried to crawl towards
it desperate to switch it off before his
suit separated from him a fist sailed
through the air and clocked Hardy Square
on the jaw Eddie had landed a hit he'd
knocked Hardy over keeping him down for
long enough so that the portion of the
Symbiote that had been removed leafed
off of the agent's body and quickly
crawled its way back to its original
host shutting the alarm off again again
Eddie was once again encased in the form
of the lethal protector and they towered
over agent Hardy long slimy tongue
unraveling from their razor tooth Jaws
just who the hell do you think you are
party spat enraged we are Venom agent
Hardy screams echo through the halls of
the site then quickly fell silent with a
meaty crunch not long after Venom
noticed that they were starting to fade
from this universe again oh Eddie it's
happening again Venom exclaimed oh we
better end up home this time Eddie
signed as they disappeared leaving the
foundation to clean up the mess that
they'd Left Behind now go check out SCP
Elite Mobile task force explained and
how to work at the SCP Foundation
explained if much like agent Hardy you
need a crash course in how a proper SCP
Foundation operative should behave